انقل اليك هذه الاخبار العاجله وبالطبع
انت لديك المزيد من التفاصيل عنها ذوي
صفارات الانذار في السدود ونيتيفوت وسلطات
الاسرائيليه تدعو السكان لدخول الملجا
الياس بالفعل فدى الدفعه الاخيره من
الصواريخ ربما شملت خمسه صواريخ اطلقت من
قطاع غزه وهذه الصواريخ كانت موجهه صوب
العمق الاسرائيلي تحديدا صوب مدينه ازدود
والمناطق الشرقيه لهذه المدينه كان يثني
وغيرها
وعلى الاقل
تمكنا ان نشاهد من هنا ونرصد لان القبه
الحديديه تمكنت من اعتراض صاروخين فقط
وبعد ذلك سمعنا سلسله من الانفجارات فيما
يؤكد بان على الاقل ثلاثه صواريخ سقطت في
تلك المناطق بانتظار ربما انباء حول حصيله
هذا السقوط الذي جرى في الساعه الاخيره
اذا الدفعه صاروخيه جديده تستهدف هذه
المره للمره الثانيه هذا النهار مدينه
اسدود
والمواقع والمناطق الواقعه الى الشرق منها
هذا اضافه الى ان الطائرات الانذار فدى
تدوي في العديد من البلدات الاسرائيليه
الواقعه في منطقه غلاف غزه وتلك القريبه
جدا من السياج الامني في الدقائق الاخيره
فيما يبدو انها موجه جديده من الدفعات
الصاروخيه وضربات الصاروخيه التي توجهها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه الى تلك البلدات
شاهدنا بالامس فدى بان المقاومه ركزت
ضربتها على الغلاف اليوم توسع ذلك الى
حدود اربعين كيلو مترا حتى هذه الساعه
وهنا سؤال لابرز الاهداف التي وصلت اليها
صواريخ المقاومه منذ صباح هذا اليوم
بالفعل يعني اوسع او ابعد الاهداف فدا هي
في نحو اربعين الى خمسين كيلو مترا من
قطاعي غزه نتحدث عن مدينه اسدود بالتحديد
وايضا المناطق الشرقيه منها
وغيرها من البلدات الاسرائيليه الصغيره
التي كانت تعرضت ايضا لقصف ودوت فيها
صافرات الانذار بالاضافه الى عشرات
البلدات الصغيره في تلك المنطقه المعروفه
ايضا بالسهل الداخلي والتي تبعد نحو ربما
عشره كيلو مترات او اكثر من ذلك بقليل عن
المنطقه الساحليه لازدود وتلك المناطق
ايضا فيها كما هو معلوم القاعده العسكريه
المهمه لاسرائيل قاعده بالمخيم التي كانت
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تحاول كما يبدو في
الايام الماضيه بلوغها وتسديد ايضا
الصواريخ باتجاهها وكان لافتا هذا اليوم
فدى بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه على الاقل
اطلقت صاروخا واحدا في الى منطقه البحر
الى جهه البحر على غير العاده ربما هذه هي
اول مره نشاهد ذلك بام العين هنا من منطقه
شمال قطاع غزه ذلك ان كل الصواريخ التي
كانت تنطلق في العمق الاسرائيلي صوب المدن
الساحليه صوب الضواحي الجنوبيه لتل ابيب
صوب المناطق الشرقيه في النقب الغربي وفي
غلاف غزه وكذلك
الصاروخان اللذان اطلقا بالامس صوب مدينه
القدس المحتله وسقطا في مناطق في الجبال
الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الغربيه
للمدينه لكن هذا الصاروخ اليوم اطلق صوب
البحر صاروخ واحد هنالك شهود عيان ايضا في
مدينه عسقلان اكدوا سقوط هذا الصاروخ في
داخل البحر وهذا يعني ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ربما تحاول تسديده ضربات
لمنصات الغاز الطبيعي التابعه لاسرائيل في
البحر المتوسط وربما تحاول ايضا استهداف
المنشات النفطيه الواقعه على الساحل
الجنوبي لمدينه عسقلان ما يعرف بخط كاتسا
هذا الخط الذي يربط مدينه عسقلان على
البحر المتوسط وينقل النفط الى مدينه
ايلات على البحر الاحمر وكان استهدف في
الماضي في جولات القتال وكان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه فدا تريد ان تقول بان النفط
مقابل النفط الوقود مقابل الوقود في اشاره
الى ربما النقص المتوقع في الوقود
لشركه الكهرباء الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه
والذي ربما ينفذ في الساعات والايام
المقبله بسبب منع اسرائيل لوصول الوقود
الى تلك المحطه واغلاق المعابر المؤديه
الى قطاع غزه